hey 42 here have you ever had a dream
that felt
extremely important no not the one where
you were naked at work
or the one where you were playing tennis
with stevie wonder
wait was that just me i mean a dream
that stayed with you
long after you woke up as if it had
something
edifying to teach you if that sounds
familiar
then you're in good company because some
fantastic ideas and discoveries have
emerged from dreams
albert einstein once had a dream that
saw him sledding down a steep
mountainside
at a velocity approaching the speed of
light
you may be thinking hey that's no dream
i did that once after a bottle of vodka
naked funnily enough albert didn't see
it as a dream either
which is how it eventually led to the
formulation
of his theory of relativity in a series
of similar slumber revelations
famed physicist niels bohr saw the
structure of the atom in a dream
long before he was able to prove it
scientifically
chemist dimitri mendeleev conceived the
periodic table
whilst taking forty winks and auguste
cooley unlocked the chemical structure
of benzene
thanks to a vision that came to him in
his sleep
that last one may not sound like a big
deal but the discovery opened up a whole
new branch of chemistry
aromatic chemistry without which we
wouldn't have some of life's
essentials like cheap polyester suits
tennis racket strings polystyrene balls
and
tie-dye t-shirts speaking
of hippies when john lennon wasn't too
busy
imagining all the people he was writing
songs
in his sleep namely the appropriately
titled
number nine dream and john wasn't the
only beetle to get creative whilst
catching up on sleep
either the melody for the beatles
classic yesterday
was simply playing in paul mccartney's
head when he woke up one day
and he's not stopped playing the damn
thing ever since
it seems that dreams are pretty powerful
things
capable of inspiring startling
scientific breakthroughs
and catalyzing captivating creativity
but what if i was to tell you that you
could have dreams like these
at will or even better that you could
control those dreams
playing out your wildest fantasies in
full hd
that you could wake up fully conscious
in your dreams
that you could fly breathe underwater
learn any skill or hook up with the man
woman or beast hopefully not beast
of your well dreams
these are the promises of lucid dreaming
an ancient practice that allows the
dreamer to gain full consciousness
whilst fast asleep sounds impossible
well thanks to neuroscience and a guy
called
stephen leberge we know it's not
le berge is a psychophysiologist
apparently that's a thing and pioneering
o naira naught apparently that is too
using regular person words he's a
scientist
and enthusiastic lucid dreamer cultures
throughout the world have been
practicing lucid dreaming techniques
for at least two millennia greek
physician
gallon of pergamon prescribed lucid
dreaming
as a form of psychotherapy and aristotle
wrote of it
often when one is asleep there is
something in consciousness
which declares that what then presents
itself
is but a dream it wasn't until the early
1980s however
that we saw scientific proof of their
validity
as it was le berge he provided it during
his time at stanford university
in controlled experiments le burge's
collaborators waited until they could
confirm he was fully asleep and dreaming
then using a set of pre-agreed eye
movements as signals
leberge was able to communicate to his
colleagues that he was
conscious or lucid since then the field
of neuroscience has exploded
thanks to radical advances in technology
that allow us to analyze the human brain
whilst the owner of
said vital organ is still alive the
previous approach was more of the
hannibal lecter variety and mostly
involved taking the top of the subject's
skull off
and having a good poke around inside a
bit like breaking a light bulb to look
for the source of the light
you can see why this method didn't yield
much in the way of results
even when scientists got to examine
albert einstein's brain for example
they could discover nothing particularly
unusual about it except that it was
slightly smaller than the average human
brain that's right
guys it turns out that size really
doesn't gray matter
by the late 20th century the refinement
of cerebral monitoring equipment
like eeg and fmri finally made it
possible to watch the human brain in
action
leading to multiple breakthroughs in our
understanding of neurobiology
one of the biggest was the discovery of
neuroplasticity
the brain's ability to change shape size
and operation in response to learning
and behavior
remember that point because it's going
to be really important later
so what does all this fancy new tech
have to do with lucid dreaming
well scientists are now able to prove
that lucid dreaming
has discernible neural correlates
which is a fancy way of saying lucid
dreaming isn't just a phenomenon of the
mind
it's physical too and if it's physical
it can be measured by analyzing
brainwaves and neurological functions
researchers have been able to prove how
lucid dreaming works
in a lucid dream you are sound asleep
but a specific part of your brain
the right dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
to be exact
has been reactivated allowing you to
experience the dream state
whilst fully aware we'll get to the
details on this later but for now
to put it simply something that is
usually switched off in your brain
whilst you dream
switches back on again and you have the
sudden recognition that
holy i'm dreaming with this
realization
comes profound power once you are
lucid in a dream you are able to take
control of your dream experience
you can do anything go anywhere be
anyone
it's like virtual reality on steroids
except you're no longer just a character
in a pre-designed game
you're the game designer and you aren't
coding for some puny games console
you have at your disposal the limitless
potential
of the human mind sounds amazing doesn't
it
and i'm sure by now you're asking the
obvious question
how can i do that before we look at some
possible answers allow me for a moment
to explain
how sleep and dreaming work every night
we go through four
primary stages of sleep in stage one
your breathing
heartbeat and eye movements begin to
slow as you move through
semi-consciousness
this is the hypnagogic state that trippy
phase between
wakefulness and sleep when you might
wonder if someone put acid in your
bedtime chamomile
it is also in this stage that you may
experience
hypnic or myoclonic jerks
involuntary muscle spasms that make you
twitch like a michael jackson backup
dancer
stage two is light dreamlessly your
muscles relax further
your breathing and brain activity slow
even more
by stage three you are in a deep
dreamless sleep
everything slows down your breathing
your heartbeat
even your brain frequencies drop to
super low frequency delta waves
it is at this stage that your body and
brain recharge and restore
deep dreamless sleep is what you need to
feel refreshed and
well rested in the morning the fourth
stage of sleep
is called rem sleep named after the
rapid eye movement that typifies this
state
not the american rock band this is where
the dream
action happens in rem sleep your brain
activity increases and your body becomes
paralyzed
so that you don't act out your dreams
which is great because it stops you from
punching yourself in your bollocks
sleep is not a one-way journey in a
normal night's sleep you will cycle
through all four stages about four
or five times with the amount of time
spent in rem
increasing with each cycle by the end of
your night's sleep
you could be spending up to 90 minutes
in dreamland
most people don't pay a second thoughts
to what happens during their nighttime
slumber
which is astonishing if you consider
that you spend about a third of your
life
fast asleep no one knows for certain
why we dream and most people think of
dreams as these
random things that just happen to them
one moment you're falling asleep
and the next moment you're arguing with
katy perry
over who gets to keep the talking
penguin lucid dreams
flip this view on its head because they
don't just happen to
you they happen for you they are there
to be explored
and played with but first you need to
learn
how just like the normal kind lucid
dreams take place during rem sleep
but they don't look and feel quite the
same
even from an outside perspective studies
conducted at frankfurt university's
neurological clinic
found that lucid dreaming constitutes a
hybrid state of consciousness
that is measurably different from both
the waking state
and the dream state in 2012
scientists from the max planck institute
of psychiatry
found that when subjects were lucidly
conscious in a dream
activity surged in the parts of their
brain associated
with self-awareness including in the
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
this was a big discovery usually when
you dream
your prefrontal cortex switches off this
makes sense
because it's responsible for most of the
clever things you do every day like
rational thought and choosing matching
socks
those faculties aren't needed in the
imagination land of dreams
where rules and logic don't apply but
it's also believed that the prefrontal
cortex
houses the roots of your personality and
sense of self so as this area of the
brain takes a break
whilst you dream it's quite easy for
your mind to accept that
you are not as most people believe
a middle-aged father of two named dave
but
rather lord zoltran defender of the
outer galaxies and all those who dwell
there
in a lucid dream though the prefrontal
cortex fires up again
and with it the sudden thought wait a
minute
my name's not really lords ultron i must
be dreaming
with that realisation a world of
infinite opportunity opens up
you start being just the star of your
dream and take on the role
of director too you can choose to join
lord's ultron in intergalactic battle
you can teleport to the center of the
earth you can change the shape of
mountains
you can have sex with a goddess and yeah
fulfilling sexual fantasies is
unsurprisingly one of the most popular
lucid dreaming pastimes
but once the novelty of that wears off
which usually takes a year
or two most experienced lucid dreamers
turn their attention to
other goals things like training and
developing
new skills remember earlier i mentioned
something called neuroplasticity the
brain's ability to adapt and
change its function and even its shape
in response to behavior or environmental
needs
what this means is that no matter how
old you are
you can train your brain to evolve and
become
better at certain things by physically
building or reinforcing
neural pathways collections of neurons
in your brain connected by dendrites
the number of dendrites increases the
more a behavior is performed
which is why the more you do something
the better you become at it
and this amazing expandability of the
brain
can be hacked professional athletes have
been acid for ages
using visualization to trick their brain
into
learning something faster by repeatedly
imagining an
action without physically doing it it
might sound crazy
but science has proven that this really
works
studies have shown that simply imagining
lifting weights every day for 12 weeks
can grow muscles without you actually
lifting a thing
lucid dreaming can be used to the same
effect
but with far greater results our
neurological system
doesn't differentiate between waking
experience
and lucid dreaming experience which
means you can
use your dreams to strengthen the normal
pathways associated with
any skills or competencies that you want
to develop
want to become a better sportsman
practice in your lucid dreams
want to learn a new language practice in
your lucid dreams
want to be a kinder more compassionate
person
just stop being a dick not only will you
accelerate your learning by spending
extra hours every night on your
development
some exercises are actually amplified by
dreaming
for example tibetan buddhist master
nam kai nobu once said that meditating
in a lucid dream
was nine times more powerful than
meditating whilst awake
you just can't argue with that kind of
maths or
small wrinkly tibetan men lucid dreaming
is also associated with mental health
and well-being
with a 1995 study suggesting that a
higher frequency of lucid dreaming
was associated with a better ability to
manage thoughts and emotions whilst
awake
and the majority of lucid dreamers 65
report that their dreams had a positive
effect on them
even if they often weren't quite able to
explain why
so self-development limitless fun better
mental well-being
sounds like lucid dreaming might be a
good hobby to get into
but how do you do it well
first up it's disclaimer time some
people seem to be hardwired for lucid
dreaming and pick it up very quickly
whilst for others it takes longer
estimates vary but between 47
and 100 of the population are thought to
have had at least one
lucid dream and many children lucid
dreams spontaneously
but if you don't remember making all the
grown-ups disappear
and manifesting the world's biggest ice
cream from those early lucid dreams of
yours
that isn't all that surprising because
the biggest block
to lucid dreaming is memory that's why
the first thing to do if you want to
start lucid dreaming
is to improve your dream recall
keep a detailed dream notebook and read
through it at night before you sleep to
better prepare your mind
for the idea of dreaming if you're
struggling to remember your dreams in
the first place
try staying motionless for a minute or
two after you wake up
nobody's sure why but keeping the same
posture as when you were dreaming
helps you to remember the dream no i
don't mean the posture you had
in the actual dream nobody ever needs to
see that
tip number two is to identify your dream
signs
dreams can be weird but sometimes things
happen that are just plain ridiculous
so next time you recall something
properly odd like
shopping with barack obama or riding a
dolphin through rush hour traffic
make a note of it in your dream record
over time
you may see certain dream signs cropping
up in your dreams regularly
so make a note of that too tip number
three involves something called
mnemonic induced lucid dreaming a
technique crafted by stephen liberge
himself
that relies on something called
prospective memory
which is the intention to do something
in the future
as you're falling asleep think of a
recent dream
or one of your dream signs and repeat
these words
over and over to yourself until you fall
asleep
for example next time i dream i will
remember that i am dreaming
and you might just do that tip number
four
involves making reality checks during
your normal waking day
this can be as simple as asking yourself
is this real
and then testing it this tip is similar
in principle to the
totems used by leonardo dicaprio and his
pals in
inception to check whether they're
dreaming you know the ones i mean
is it spinning is it about to stop
spinning is christopher nolan really
going to end the whole effing movie
like this if you can make reality checks
a habit the theory goes that your brain
will start performing them
whilst you're sleeping and wham you'll
just realize that you're dreaming
and become lucid my final tip is called
the wake back to bed technique which
involves
interrupting your natural sleep cycle to
optimize your most active dream period
of the night
set your alarm for five to six hours
after bedtime
when the alarm goes off get out of bed
and stay awake for
20 to 60 minutes then get back to bed
this has the effect of stimulating your
conscious brain at a time
when you normally would be experiencing
rem sleep
so that when you go back to sleep you'll
drop straight back into rem sleep from a
conscious state
and begin to lucid dream
these techniques won't work for everyone
but if they work for you you
might just be in for one of the wildest
adventures of your life
let me know what you decide to do the
first time you wake up fully conscious
in your own dream
in the comments section below actually
on second thoughts don't do that
thanks for watching you can now
pre-order my brand new book stick a flag
in it on amazon
link in the description thank you